The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So as
you recall last time
we talked about chromatin
structure and chromatin
regulation.
And now we're going to move
on to genetic analysis.
But before we did that, I
want us to touch on two points
that we talked about
briefly last time.
One was 5C analysis.
Who was it that brought up--
who was the 5C expert here?
Anybody?
No?
Nobody wants to own 5C.
OK.
But as you recall, we
talked about ChIA-PET
as one way of analyzing any
to any interactions in the way
that the genome folds up and
enhancers talk to promoters.
And 5C is a very
similar technique.
I just wanted to
show you the flow
chart for how the protocol goes.
There is a cross linking.
A digestion with a
restriction enzyme
step, followed by a
proximity ligation step,
which gives you molecules
that had been brought together
by an enhancer, promoter
complex, or any other kind
of distal protein-protein
interaction.
And then, what happens is that
you design specific timers
to detect those ligation events.
And you sequence
the result of what
is known as ligation
mediated amplification.
So those primers are
only going to ligate
if they're brought together at
a particular junction, which
is defined by the
restriction sites lining up.
So, 5C is a method of looking
at which regions of the genome
interact and can produce
these sorts of results,
showing which
parts of the genome
interact with one another.
The key difference, I think,
between chIA-PET and 5C
is that you actually have to
have these primers designed
and pick the particular
locations you want to query.
So the primers that you design
represent query locations
and you can then either apply
the results to a microarray,
or to high throughput sequencing
to detect these interactions.
But the essential
idea is the same.
Where you do proximity
based ligation
to form molecules that
contain components
of two different
pieces of the genome
that have been brought together
for some functional reason.
The next thing I
want to touch upon
was this idea of the
CpG dinucleotides
that are connected
by a phosphate bond.
And you recall that I
talked about the idea
that they were symmetric.
So you could have methyl groups
on the cytosines in such a way
that, because they could
mirror one another,
they could be transferred
from one strand of DNA
to the other strand of DNA,
during cell replication
by DNA methyltransferase.
So it forms a more stable kind
of mark and as you recall,
DNA methylation where
something occurred
in lowly expressed genes
and typically in regions
of the genome that
are methylated.
Other histone marks
are not present
and the genes are turned off.
OK.
So those were the
points I wanted
to touch upon from last lecture.
Now we're going to
embark upon an adventure,
looking for the answer to, wear
is missing heritability found?
So it's a big open
question now in genetics.
In human genetics,
which is that we really
can't find all the heritability.
And as a point of
introduction, the narrative
arc for today's lecture is
that, generally speaking,
you're more like your
relatives than random people
on the planet.
And why is this?
Well obviously you contain
components of your mom
and dad's genomes.
And they are providing you
with components of your traits.
And the heritability
of a trait is
defined by the fraction
of phenotypic variance
that can be explained
by genetics.
And we're going to talk today
about computational models that
can predict phenotype
from genotype.
And this is very
important, obviously,
for understanding the sources of
various traits and phenotypes.
As well as fields such
as pharmacogenomics
that try and predict the
best therapy for a disease
based upon your genetic makeup.
So, individual
loci in the genome
that contribute to
quantitative traits
are called quantitative
trait locis, or QTLs.
So we're going to talked
about how to discover them
and how to build models of
quantitative traits using QTLs.
And finally, as I
said at the outset,
our models are
insufficient today.
They really can't find
all of the heritability.
So we're going to go searching
for this missing heritability
and see where it might be found.
Computationally, we're going to
apply a variety of techniques
to these problems.
A preview is, we're
going to build
linear models of
phenotype and we're
going to use stepwise regression
to learn these models using
a forward feature selection.
And I'll talk about
what that is when
we get to that point
of the lecture.
We're going to derive test
statistics for discovering
which QTLs are significant
and which QTLs are not,
to include in our model.
And finally, we're
going to talk about how
to measure narrow sense
heritability and broad sense
heritability in
environmental variance.
OK.
So, one great resource for
traits that are fairly simple.
That primarily are the result
of a single gene mutation,
or where a single gene
mutation plays a dominant role,
is something called Online
Mendelian Inheritance in Man.
And it's a resource.
It has about 21,000
genes in it right now.
And it's a great way to explore
what human genes function
is in various diseases.
And you could query by disease.
You can query by gene.
And it is a very carefully
annotated and maintained
collection that is
worthy of study,
if you're interested in
particular disease genes.
We're going to be looking at
more complex analyses today.
The analyses we're
going to look at
are where there
are many genes that
influence a particular trait.
And we would like to come
up with general methods
for discovering how we can de
novo from experimental data--
discover all the different
genes that participate.
Now just as a quick
review of statistics,
I think that we've talked
before about means in class
and variances.
We're also going to
talk a little bit
about covariances today.
But these are terms
that you should
be familiar with as
we're looking today
at some of our metrics for
understanding heritability.
Are there any question about any
of the statistical metrics that
are up here?
OK.
So, a broad overview of
genotype to phenotype.
So, we're primarily
going to be working
with complete genome
sequences today,
which will reveal all
of the variance that
are present in the genome.
And it's also the case that
you can subsample a genome
and only observe
certain variance.
Typically that's
done with microarrays
that have probes that are
specific to particular markers.
The way those arrays
are manufactured
is that whole genome sequencing
is done at the outset, and then
high prevalence
variance, at least
common variance,
which typically are
at a frequency of at
least 5% in the population
are queried by
using a microarray.
But today we'll talk about
complete genome sequence.
An individual's
phenotype, we'll say
is defined by one
or more traits.
And a non-quantitative trait is
something perhaps as simple as
whether or not something
is dead or alive.
Or whether or not it can survive
in a particular condition.
Or its ability to produce
a particular substance.
A quantitative trait,
on the other hand,
is a continuous variable.
Height, for example,
of an individual
is a quantitative trait.
As is growth rate, expression
of a particular gene,
and so forth.
So we'll be focusing today on
estimating quantitative traits.
And as I said, a
quantitative trait or loci,
is a marker that's associated
with a quantitative trait
and could be used to predict it.
And you can sometimes
hear about eQTLs,
which are expression
quantitative trait loci.
And they're loci that are
related to gene expression.
So, let's begin then, with
a very simple genetic model.
It's going to be haploid,
which means, of course,
there's only one copy
of each chromosome.
Yeast is the model
organism we're
going to be talking about today.
It's a haploid organism.
And we have mom
and dad up there.
Mom on the left, dad on the
right in two different colors.
And you can see that mom and
dad in this particular example,
have n different genes.
They're going to contribute to
the F1 generation, to junior.
And the relative color is
white for mom, black for dad,
are going to be used to
describe the alleles,
or the allelic variance
that are inherited
by the child, the F1 generation.
And as I said, a
specific phenotype
might be alive or dead in
a specific environment.
And note that I have drawn the
chromosomes to be disconnected.
Which means that each
one of those genes
is going to be
independently inherited.
So the probability
in the F1 generation
that you're going to get
one of those from mom or dad
is going to be a coin flip.
We're going to
assume that they're
far enough away that the
probability of crossing over
during meiosis is 0.5.
And so we get a
random assortment
of alleles from mom and dad.
OK?
So let us say that you go
off and do an experiment.
And you have 32 individuals
that you produce out of a cross.
And you test them, OK.
And two of them are resistant
to a particular substance.
How many genes do you think are
involved in that resistance?
Let's assume that mom is
resistant and dad is not.
OK.
If you had two that were
resistant out of 32,
how many different genes
do you think were involved?
How do you estimate that?
Any ideas?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you
had 32 individuals
and say half of them got it?
PROFESSOR: Two, let's say.
One out of 16 is resistant.
And mom is resistant.
AUDIENCE: Because I was thinking
that if it was half of them
were resistant, then you
would maybe guess one gene,
or something like that.
PROFESSOR: Very good.
AUDIENCE: So then
if only eight were
resistant you might guess two
genes, or something like that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
What you say is, that
if mom's resistant, then
we're going to
assume that you need
to get the right number of
genes from mom to be resistant.
Right?
And so, let's say that you had
to get four genes from mom.
What's the chance of
getting four genes from mom?
AUDIENCE: Half to
the power of four.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, which
is one out of 16, right?
So, if you, for example had two
that were resistant out of 32,
the chances are one in 16.
Right?
So you would naively
think, and properly so,
that you had to give four
genes from mom to be resistant.
So the way to think
about these sorts
of non-quantitative
traits is that you
can estimate the number
of genes involved.
The simply is log
base 2 over the number
of F1s tested over the number
of the F1s with the phenotype.
It tells you roughly
how many genes
are involved in providing
a particular trait,
assuming that the
genes are unlinked.
It's a coin flip, whether
you get them or not.
Does everybody see that?
Yes?
Any questions at all about that?
About the details?
OK.
Let's talk now about
quantitative traits then.
We'll go back to our
model and imagine
that we have the
same set-- actually
it's going to a
different set of n genes.
We're going to have
a coin flip as to
whether or not you're getting
a mom gene or a dad gene.
OK.
And each gene in dad has
an effect size of 1 over n.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to check.
We're assuming that the parents
are homozygous for the trait?
Is that correct?
PROFESSOR: Remember
these are haploid.
AUDIENCE: Oh, these are haploid.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So they only have one
copy of all these genes.
All right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] resistant
and they're [INAUDIBLE].
That could still
mean that dad has
three of the four
genes in principle.
PROFESSOR: The previous slide?
Is that where what
you're talking about?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
knew about it.
So really what you mean
is that dad does not
have any of the genes that
are involved with resistance.
PROFESSOR: The correct.
I was saying that dad
has to have all of gene--
that the child has to
have all of the genes that
are operative to
create resistance.
We're going to
assume an AND model.
He must have all
the genes from mom.
They're involved in
the resistance pathway.
And since only one
out of a 16 progeny
has all those genes
from mom, right, it
appears that given the chance
of inheriting something from mom
is 1/2, that it's four genes
you have to inherit from mom.
Because the chance of inheriting
all four is one out of 16.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
in which case--
PROFESSOR: No, I'm assuming the
dad doesn't have any of those.
But here we're asking,
what is the difference
in the number of genes
between mom and dad?
So you're right, that the
number we're computing
is the relative number of genes
different between mom and dad
you require.
And so it might be
that dad's a reference
and we're asking how many
additional genes mom brought
to the table to provide
with that resistance.
But that's a good point.
OK.
So, now let's look at
this quantitative model.
Let's assume that mom has a
bunch of genes that contribute
zero to an effect size
and dad-- each gene
that dad has produces
an effect of 1 over n.
So the total effect
size here for dad is 1.
So the effect of mom on this
particular quantitative trait
might be zero.
It might be the amount
of ethanol produced
or some other
quantitative value.
And dad, on the other
hand, since he has n genes,
is going to produce one,
because each gene contributes
a little bit to this
quantitative phenotype.
Is everybody clear on that?
So, the child is
going to inherit genes
to our coin flip between
mom and dad, right.
So the first
fundamental question
is, how many different
levels are there
in our quantitative
phenotype in our trait?
How many different
levels can you have?
AUDIENCE: N + 1?
PROFESSOR: N + 1, right,
because you can either inherit
zero, or up to n genes from dad.
And it gets you n plus
1 different levels.
OK.
So, what's the
probability then-- well,
I'll ask a different question.
What's the expected value of
the quantitative phenotype
of a child?
Just looking at this.
If dad's one and mom's zero, and
you have a collection of genes
and you do a coin
flip each time,
you're going to get
half your genes from mom
and half your genes from dad.
Right.
And so the expected
trait value is 0.5.
So for these added
traits, you're
going be at the midpoint
between mom and dad.
Right.
And what is the
probability that you
inherit x copies of dad's genes?
Well, that's n choose x, times
1 minus .5 n to the minus
x times 0.5 to the x.
A simple binomial.
Right.
So if you look at
this, the probability
of the distribution
for the children
is going to look
something like this,
where this is the mean, 0.5.
And the number of distinct
values is going to be n plus 1.
Right.
So the expected value of
x is 0.5 and turns out
that the expected value, or the
variance of x minus 0.5, which
is the mean squared, is
going to be 0.25 over n.
So I can show you this
on the next slide.
So you can see, this could
be ethanol production,
it could be growth
rate, what have you.
And you can see that the
number of genes that you're
going to get from dad follows
this binomial distribution
and gives you a spread
of different phenotypes
in the child's
generation, depending
upon how many copies of
dad's genes that you inherit.
But does this make
sense to everybody?
Now would be a great
time to ask any questions
about the details of this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you
clarify what x is?
Is x the fraction
of genes inherited--
PROFESSOR: The number of
genes you inherit from dad.
The number of genes.
So it would zero,
one, two, up to n.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't the
expectation of n [INAUDIBLE]
x be n/2?
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
It is supposed to be n/2.
But the last two
expectations are
some of the number of genes
you've inherited from dad.
Right, that's correct.
Yeah, this slide's wrong.
Any other questions?
OK.
So this is a very simple
model but it tells us
a couple of things, right.
Which is that as n
gets to be very large,
the effect of each gene
gets to be quite small.
So something could be
completely heritable,
but if it's spread
over, say 1,000 genes,
then it will be very
difficult to detect,
because the effect of each
gene would be quite small.
And furthermore, the variance
that you see in the offspring
will be quite small
as well, right,
in terms of the phenotype.
Because it's going to be 0.25/n
in terms of the expected value.
So as n gets larger,
the number genes that
contribute to that
phenotype increase,
the variance is going
to go down linearly.
OK.
So we should just
keep this in mind
as we're looking at discovering
these sort of traits
and the underlying QTLs that
can be used to predict them.
And finally, I'd like to point
out one other detail which
is that, if genes
are linked, that is,
if they're in close proximity
to one another in the genome
and it makes it very
unlikely there's
going to be crossing
over between them,
then they're going
to act as a unit.
And if they act as a unit, then
we'll get marker correlation.
And you can also
see, effectively,
that the effect size
of those two genes
is going to be larger.
And in more complicated
models, we obviously
wouldn't have the same
effect size for each gene.
The effect size might be
quite large for some genes,
might be quite small
for some genes.
And we'll see the effects
of marker correlation
in a little bit.
So the way we're going to model
this is we're going to-- this
is a definition of the
variables that we're
going to be talking about today.
And the essential
idea is quite simple.
So the phenotype of an
individual-- so p sub
i is the phenotype
of an individual,
is going to be equal to some
function of their genotype
plus an environmental component.
This function is the critical
thing that we want to discover.
This function, f, is
mapping from the genotype
of an individual
to its phenotype.
And the environmental
component could
be how well something is fed,
how much sunlight it gets,
things that can greatly
influence things like growth
but they're not
described by genetics.
But this function is
going to encapsulate
what we know about
how the genetics
of a particular individual
influences a trait.
And thus, if we consider a
population of individuals,
the phenotypic
variance is going to be
equal to the genotypic variance
plus the environmental variance
plus two times the covariance
between the genotype
in the environment.
And we're going to assume,
as most studies do,
that there is no
correlation between genotype
and environment.
So this term disappears.
So what we're left with is
that the observed phenotypic
variance is equal to
the genotypic variance
plus the environmental variance.
And what we would like to do
is to come up with a function
f, that best predicts
the genotypic component
of this equation.
There's nothing we can do
about environmental variance.
Right.
But we can measure it.
Does anybody have
any ideas how we
could measure
environmental variance?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Study
populations in which
there's some kind of
controlled environment.
So you study populations
that one population
is one with a homogeneous.
And another one was a
completely different one.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So what we could do is
we could use controls.
So typically what we could do is
we could study in environments
where we try and control
the environment exactly
to eliminate this as much as
we possibly can, for example.
As we'll see that we
also can do things
like study clones,
where individuals
have exactly the same genotype.
And then, all of the
variance that we observe--
if this term vanishes because
the genotypes are identical,
it is due to the environment.
So typically, if
you're doing things
like studying humans, since
cloning humans isn't really
a good idea to actually
measure environmental variance,
right, what you could do is you
can look at identical twins.
And identical twins
give you a way
to get at the question of
how much environment variance
there is for a
particular phenotype.
So in sum, this is
replicates what I have here
on the left-hand
side of the board.
And note that today
we'll be talking
about the idea of
discovering this function,
f, and how well
we can discover f,
which is really
important, right.
It's fundamental to be
able to predict phenotype
from genotype.
It's an extraordinarily
central question in genetics.
And when we do the prediction,
there are two kinds of-- oh,
there's a question?
AUDIENCE: Could you
please explain again
why the co-variance drops
out or it goes away.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the
co-variance drops out
because we're going to
assume that genotype
and environment are independent.
Now if they're not
independent, it won't drop out.
But making that assumption--
and of course, for human studies
you can't really make that
assumption completely, right?
And one of the problems in
doing these sorts of studies
is that it's very, very
easy to get confounded.
Because when you're
trying to decompose
the observed variance
and height, for example.
You know, there's what mom and
dad provided to an individual
in terms of their
height, and there's also
how much junior ate, right.
And whether he went to
McDonald's a lot, or you know,
was going to Whole Foods a lot.
You know, who knows, right?
But this component
and this component,
it's easy to get
confounded between them
and sometimes you can
imagine that genotype
is related to place of
origin in the world.
And that has a lot to
do with environment.
And so this term wouldn't
necessarily disappear.
OK.
So there are two
kinds of heritability
I'd like to touch upon today.
And it's important that you
remember there are two kinds
and one is extraordinarily
difficult to recover
and the other one is in some
sense, a more constrained
problem, because we're much
better at building models
for that kind of
heritability estimate.
The first is broad-sense
heritability,
which describes the upper bound
for phenotypic prediction given
an arbitrary model.
So it's the total contribution
to phenotypic variance
from genetic causes.
And we can estimate that, right.
And we'll see how we can
estimate it in a moment.
And narrow-sense
heritability is defined as,
how much of the
heritability can we describe
when we restrict f
to be a linear model.
So when f is simply linear,
as the sum of terms,
that describes the maximum
narrow-sense heritability we
can recover in terms of
the fraction of phenotypic
variance we can capture in f.
And it's very useful
because it turns out
that we can compute both
broad-sense and narrow-sense
heritability from
first principles-- I
mean from experiment.
And the difference between them
is part of our quest today.
Our quest is, to
answer the question,
where is the missing
heritability?
Why can't we build an
Oracle f that perfectly
predicts phenotype
from genotype?
So on that line-- I just want
to give you some caveats.
One is that we're always talking
about populations when we're
talking about
heritability because it's
how we're going to estimate it.
And when you hear people
talk about heritability,
oftentimes they won't
qualify it in terms
of whether it's broad-sense
or narrow-sense.
And so you should
ask them if you're
engaged in a scientific
discussion with them.
And as we've already
discussed, sometimes estimation
is difficult because of matching
environment and eliminating
this term, the
environmental term
can be a challenge when
you're out of the laboratory.
Like when you're
dealing with humans.
So, let's talk about
broad-sense heritability.
Imagine that we measure
environmental variants simply
by looking at environmental
twins or clones, right.
Because if we, for example,
take a bunch of yeast
that are genotypically
identical.
And we grow them up
separately, and we
measure a trait like
how well they respond
to a particular chemical
or their growth rate,
then the variance we see from
each individual to individual
is simply environmental, because
they're genetically identical.
So
we can, in that
particular case, exactly
quantify the
environmental variance
given that every individual
is genetically identical.
We simply measure
all the growth rates
and we compute the variance.
And that's the
environmental variance.
OK?
As I said for humans, the best
we can do is identical twins.
Monozygotic twins.
You can go out and for pairs
of twins that are identical,
you can measure height or
any other trait that you like
and compute the variance.
And then that is an estimate
of the environmental component
of that, because they should
be genetically identical.
And big H squared--
broad-sense is always
capital H squared and
narrow-sense is always
little h squared.
Big H squared,
which is broad-sense
heritability is
very simple then.
It's the phenotypic variance,
minus the environmental
variance, over the
phenotypic variance.
So it's the fraction of
phenotypic experience
that can be explained
from genetic causes.
Is that clear to everybody?
Any questions at all about this?
OK.
So, for example, on the
right-hand hand side
here, those three
purplish squares
have three different
populations,
which are genotypically
identical.
They have two genes, a little a,
a little a, big A, a little A,
and big A, big A. And each
one is a variance of 1.0.
out So since there are
genetically identical,
we know that the environmental
variance has to be 1.0.
On the left-hand side, you
see the genotypic variance.
And that reminds us of
where we started today.
It depends on the number of
alleles you get of big A,
as to what the value is.
And when you put all
of that together,
you get a total variance of 3.
And so big H squared is
simply the genotypic variance,
which is 2, over the total
phenotypic variance, which
is 3.
So big H squared is 2/3.
And so that is a
way of computing
broad-sense heritability.
Now, if we think
about our models,
we can see that
narrow-sense heritability
has some very nice properties.
Right.
That is, if we build and
add a model of phenotype,
to get at narrow-sense
heritability.
So if we were to constraint
f here to be linear,
it's simply going to be a
very simple linear model.
For each particular
QTL that we discover,
we assign an effect
size beta to it,
or a coefficient that
describes its deviation
from the mean for
that particular trait.
And we have an
offset, beta zero.
So our simple linear model is
going to take all the discovery
QTLs that we have--
take each QTL
and discover which
allelic form it's in.
Typically it's considered
either in zero or one form.
And then add a beta j, where
j is the particular QTL
deviation from mean value.
Add them all together to
compute the phenotype.
OK.
So, this is a very
simple additive model
and a consequence
of this model is
that if you think about an
F1 or a child of two parents,
as we said earlier, a child is
going to inherit roughly half
of the alleles from mom and
half of the alleles from dad.
And so for additive
models like this,
the expected value of
the child's trait value
is going to be the
midpoint of mom and dad.
And that can be derived
directly from the equation
above, because you're
getting half of the QTLs
from mom and half of
the QTLs from dad.
So this was observed a
long time ago, right,
because if you did studies and
you looked at the deviation
from the midpoint of
parents for human height.
You can see that the
children fall pretty
close to mid-parent line,
where the y-axis here
is the height in inches
and that suggests
that much of human height can be
modeled by a narrow-sense based
heritability model.
Now, once again,
narrow-sense heritability
is the fraction of
phenotypic variance explained
by an additive model.
And we've talked before
about the model itself.
And little h squared
is simply going
to be the amount of
variance explained
by the additive model over
the total phenotypic variance.
And the additive variance is
shown on the right-hand side.
That equation boils down to,
you take the phenotypic variance
and you subtract off the
variance that's environmental
and that cannot be explained
by the additive variance,
and what you're left with
is the additive variance.
And once again, coming
back to the question
of missing heritability,
if we observe
that what we can estimate
for little h squared
is below what we
expect, that gap
has to be explained somehow.
Some typical values for
theoretical h squared.
So this is not
measured h squared
in terms of building a model
and testing it like this.
But what we can do is
we can theoretically
estimate what h
squared should be,
by looking at the fraction of
identity between individuals.
Morphological
traits tend to have
higher h squared for
the fitness traits.
So human height has a little
h square of about 0.8.
And for those ranchers
out there in the audience,
you'll be happy to know that
cattle yearly weight has
heritability of about 0.35.
Now, things like life history
which are fitness traits
are less heritable.
Which would suggest that looking
at how long your parents lived
and trying to estimate how
long you're going to live
is not as productive as
looking at how tall you
are compared to your parents.
And there's a complete
table that I've
included in the slides
for you to look at,
but it's too small to
read on the screen.
OK, so now we're going to
turn to computational models
and how we can discover
a model that figures out
where the QTLs are, and then
assigns that function f to them
so we can predict
phenotype from genotype.
And we're going to be taking
our example from this paper
by Bloom, et al, which I
posted on the Stellar site.
And it came out
last year and it's
wonderful study in QTL analysis.
And the setup for this
study is quite simple.
What they did was, is they
took two different strains
of yeast, RM and BY,
and they crossed them
and produced roughly 1,000 F1s.
And RM and BY are very similar.
They are about, I think
it's about 35,000 snips
between them.
Only about 0.5% of their
genomes are different.
So they're really close.
Just for point of reference, you
know, the distance between me
and you is something like
one base for every thousand?
Something like that.
And then they assayed
all those F1s.
They genotyped them all.
So to genotype
them, what you do is
you know what the
parental genotypes are
because they sequence
both parents.
The mom and dad, so to
speak, at 50x coverage.
So they knew the genome
sequence is completely
for both mom and dad.
And then for each
one of the 1,000 F1s
they put them on a
microarray and what
is shown on the
very bottom left is
a result of genotype
in an individual
where they can see
each chromosome
and whether it came
from mom or from dad.
And you can't see
it here, but there
are 16 different chromosomes
and the alternating purple and
yellow colors show whether that
particular part of the genome
came from mom or from dad.
So they know for each
individual, its source.
From the left or
the right strain.
OK.
And they have a thousand
different genetic makeups.
And then they asked, for each
one of those individuals,
how well could they grow
in 46 different conditions?
So they exposed them
to different sugars,
to different unfavorable
environments and so forth.
And they measured growth rate
as shown on the right-hand side.
Or right in the middle,
that little thing
that looks like a bunch of
little dots of various sizes.
By measuring colony
size, they could
measure how well the
yeast were growing.
And so they had two
different things, right.
They had the exact genotype
of each individual,
and they also had
how well it was
growing in a
particular condition.
And so for each
condition, they wanted
to associate the genotype
of the individual
to how well it was growing.
To its phenotype.
Now, one fair question is, of
these different conditions,
how many of them were
really independent?
And so to analyze
that, they looked
at the correlation
between growth rates
across conditions to try and
figure out whether or not
they actually had 46 different
traits they were measuring.
So this is a
correlation matrix that
is too small to
read on the screen.
The colors are somewhat
visible, where the blue colors
are perfect correlation
and the red colors
are perfect anti-correlation.
And you can see that in
certain areas of this grid,
things are more
correlated, like what
sugars the yeast liked to eat.
But suffice to say, they
had a large collection
of traits they
wanted to estimate.
So, now we want to build
a computational model.
So our next step
is figuring out how
to find those places
in the genome that
allows us to predict,
how well, given a trait,
the yeast would grow.
The actual growth rate.
So the key idea is this-- you
have genetic markers, which
are snips down the
genome and you're
going to test a
particular marker.
And if this is a
particular trait,
one possibility is
that-- let's say
that this marker could
be either 0 or 1.
Without loss of
generality, it could
be that here are all
the individuals where
the marker is zero.
And here are all the markers
where the marker is 1.
And really, fundamentally,
whether an individual
has a 0 or a 1 marker,
it doesn't really
change its growth
rate very much.
OK?
It's more or less identical.
It's also possible
that this is best
modeled by two different
means for a given trait.
That when the marker is 1,
you're growing-- actually
this is going to be the
growth rate on the x-axis.
The y-axis is the density.
That you're growing much
better when you have a 1
in that marker
position than a zero.
And so we need to distinguish
between these two cases
when the marker is
predictive of growth rate
and when the marker is not
predictive of growth rate.
And we've talked about lod
likelihood tests before
and you can see one
on the very top.
And you can see there's an
additional degree of freedom
that we have in the top
prediction versus the bottom
because we're using two
different means that
are conditioned upon
the genotypic value
at a particular marker.
So we have a lot of
different markers indeed.
So we have-- let's see
here, the exact number.
I think it's about 13,000
markers they had in this study.
No.
11,623 different unique
markers they found.
That they could discover,
that weren't linked together.
We talked about
linkage earlier on.
So you've got over
11,000 markers.
You're going to do
a lod likelihood
test to compute
this lod odds score.
Do we have to worry about
multiple hypothesis correction
here?
Because you're
testing over 11,000
markers to see
whether or not they're
significant for one trait.
Right.
So one thing that we could do
is imagine that what we did was
we scrambled the association
between phenotypes
and individuals.
So we just randomized it and
we did that a thousand times.
And each time we did it, we
computed the distribution
of these lod scores.
Because we have broken the
association between phenotype
and genotype, the
lod scores which
we should be seeing if we
did this randomization,
should correspond to
essentially noise.
But we would see it random.
So it's a null distribution
we can look at.
And so what we'll see is a
distribution of lod scores.
This is the lod.
This is the probability from
a null, a permutation test.
And since we actually have
done the randomization
over all 11,000 markers,
we can directly draw a line
and ask what are the chances
that a lod score would
be greater than or equal to
a particular value at random?
And we can pick an
area inside this tail,
let's say 0.05,
because that's what
the authors of this
particular paper used
and ask what value
of a lod score
would be very unlikely
to have by chance?
It turns out in their first
iteration, it was 2.63.
That a lod score over
2.63 had a 0.05 chance
or less of occurring in
randomly permuted data.
And since a permuted data
contained all of the markers,
we don't have to do any
multiple hypothesis correction.
So you can directly
compare the statistic
that you compute
against a threshold
and accept any marker or QTL
that has a lod score greater,
in this case then 2.63
and put it in your model.
And everything else
you can reject.
And so you start by
building a model out
of all of the markers
that are significant
at this particular level.
You then assemble the
model and you can now
predict phenotype from genotype.
But of course, you're going
to make errors, right.
For each individual, there's
going to be an error.
You're going to have a residual
for each individual that
is going to be the
phenotype minus the genotype
of the individual.
So this is the error
that you're making.
So what these folks
did was that you first
look at predicting the
phenotype directly,
and you pick all the QTLs that
are significant at that level.
And then you compute
the residuals
and you try and
predict the residuals.
And you try and
find additional QTLs
that are significant after you
have picked the original ones.
OK.
So why might this produce more
QTLs then the original pass?
What do you think?
Why is it that trying to
predict the residuals is
a good idea after
you've tried to predict
the phenotype directly?
Any ideas about that?
Well, what this
is telling us, is
that these QTLs we're
going to predict now
were not significant enough
in the original pass,
but when we're looking at what's
left over, after we subtract
off the effect of
all the other QTLs,
other things might pop up.
But in some sense, we're
obscured by the original QTLs.
Once we subtract
off their influence,
we can see things that
we didn't see before.
And we start gathering
up these additional QTLs
to predict the
residual components.
And so they do this three times.
So they predict the
original set of QTLs
and then they iterate
three time on the residuals
to find and fit a linear
model that predicts a given
trait from a collection of
QTLs that they discover.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I'm still confused.
The second round? [INAUDIBLE]
done three additional times?
Is that right?
So the--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it done
on the remainder of QTL
or on the original
list of every--
PROFESSOR: Each time
you expand your model
to include all the QTLs you've
discovered up to that point.
So initially, you discover a
set of QTLs, call that set one.
You then compute a
model using set one
and you discover the residuals.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Correct.
Well, residual
[INAUDIBLE] so you use
set one to build a
model, a phenotype.
So set one is used here
to compute this, right.
And so set one is used.
And then you compute
what's left over
after you've discovered
the first set of QTLs.
Now you say, we still
have this left to go.
Let's discover some more QTLs.
And now you discover
set two of QTLs.
OK.
And that set two then is used to
build a model that has set one
and set two in it.
Right.
And that residual
is used to discover
set three and so forth.
So each time you're
expanding the set of QTLs
by what you've discovered
in the residuals.
Sort of in the trash
bin so to speak.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Each time you're
doing this randomization
to determine lod cutoff?
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
Each time you have to
redo the randomization
and get to the lod cutoff.
AUDIENCE: But does
that method actually
work the way you expect it on
the second pass, given that you
have some false
positives from the pass
that you've now
subtracted from your data?
PROFESSOR: I'm not sure I
understand the question.
AUDIENCE: So the second time
you do this randomization,
and you again come
up with a threshold,
you say, oh, above here
there are 5% false positives.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: But could it be
that that estimate is actually
significantly wrong based the
fact that you've subtracted off
false positives before
you do that process?
PROFESSOR: I mean,
in some sense, what's
your definition of
a false positive?
Right.
I mean it gets down
to that because we've
discovered there's an
association between that QTL
and predicting phenotype.
And in this particular world
it's useful for doing that.
So it's hard to call something
a false positive in that sense,
right.
But you're right,
you actually have
to reset your
threshold every time
that you go through
this iteration.
Good question.
Other questions?
OK.
So, let's see what
happens when you do this.
What happens is that if
you look down the genome,
you discover a collection.
For example, this is
growth in E6 berbamine.
And you can see the
significant locations
in the genome, the numbers 1
through 16 of the chromosomes
and the little red
asterisks above the peaks
indicate that that was
a significant lod score.
The y-axis is a lod score.
And you can see the
locations in the genome
where we have found places that
were associated with growth
rate in that
particular chemical.
OK.
Now, why is it, do you think,
that in many of those places
you see sort of a rise and
fall that is somewhat gentle
as opposed to having
an impulse function
right at that particular spot?
AUDIENCE: Nearby
snips are linked?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, nearby
snips are linked.
That as you come up to
a place that is causal,
you get a lot of other
things are linked to that.
And the closer you get, the
higher the correlation is.
So that is for 1,000
segregants in the top.
And what was discovered
for that particular trait,
was 15 different
loci that explained
78% of the phenotypic variance.
And in the bottom,
the same procedure
was used, but was only
used on 100 segregants.
And what you can see is that,
in this particular case,
only two loci were
discovered that explain
21% of the variance.
So the bottom study was
grossly under powered.
Remember we talked about
the problem of finding
QTLs that had
small effect sizes.
And if you don't have
enough individuals
you're going to be under-powered
and you can't actually
identify all of the QTLs.
So this is a comparison of this.
And of course, one of the
things that you don't know
is the environmental variance
that you're fighting against.
Because the number
of individuals
you need, depends both on
the number of potential loci
that you have.
The more loci you have, the more
individuals you need to fight
against the multiple
hypotheses problem,
which is taken care of by
this permutation implicitly.
And the more QTLs
that contribute
to a particular trait,
the smaller they might be.
And there you need
more individuals
to provide adequate
power for your test.
And out of this
model, however, if you
look at for all the different
traits, the predictive insight
versus the observed
phenotype, you
can see that the model
does a reasonably good job.
So the interesting things
that came out of the study
were that, first of all,
it was possible to look
at the effect sizes of each QTL.
Now, the effect size in terms of
fraction of variance explained
of a particular marker, is
the square of its coefficient.
It's the beta squared.
So you can see here the
histogram of effect sizes,
and you can see that most
QTLs have very small effects
on phenotype where phenotype
is scaled between 0 and 1
for this study.
So, most traits
as described here
have between 5 and 29 different
QTL loci in the genome.
They're used to describe
them with a median of 12.
Now, the question
the authors asked,
was if they looked at the
theoretical h squared that they
computed for the F1s, how
well did their model do?
And you can see that their
model does very well.
That, in terms of looking at
narrow sense heritability,
they can recover almost
all of it, all the time.
However, the problem comes here.
Remember we talked
about how to compute
broad-sense heritability
by looking at clones
and computing environmental
variance directly.
And so they were able to
compute broad-sense heritability
and compare that the
narrow-sense heritability
that they were able to
actually achieve in the study.
And you can see there
are substantial gaps.
So what could be
making up those gaps?
Why is it that this additive
model can't explain growth rate
in a particular condition?
So, the next thing that
we're going to discover
are some of the sources of this
so-called missing heritability.
But before I give you
some of the stock answers
that people in the field give,
since this is part of our quest
today to actually look
into missing heritability,
I'll put it to you,
my panel of experts.
What could be causing this
heritability to go missing?
Why can't this additive model
predict growth rate accurately,
given it knows the
genotype exactly?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that you wouldn't
detect from looking
at the DNA sequence.
PROFESSOR: So
epidemic factors-- are
you talking about protein
factors or are you
talking about
epigenetic effects?
AUDIENCE: More of
the epigenetic marks.
PROFESSOR: Epigenetic marks, OK.
So it might be now, yeast
doesn't have DNA methylation.
It does have chromatin
modifications
in the form of histone marks.
So it might be that there's
some histone marks that
are copied from generation
to generation that are not
counted for in our model.
right?
OK, that's one possibility.
Great.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: There could
be more complex effects
so two separate genes may come
out, other than just adding.
One could turn the other off.
So it one's on, it
could [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So those are called
epistatic effects,
or they're non-linear effects.
They're gene-gene
interaction effects.
That's actually
thought to be one
of the major issues in
missing heritability.
What else could there be?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you're saying that there
could be inherent noise that
would cause there to be
fluctuations in colony size
that are unrelated
to the genotype.
And, in fact,
that's a good point.
And that's something
that we're going
to take care of with the
environmental variance.
So we're going to measure
how well individuals
grow with exactly the same
genotype in a given condition.
And so that kind of
fluctuation would
appear in that variance term.
And we're going to
get rid of that.
But that's a good thought and
I think it's important and not
appreciated that there
can be random fluctuations
in that term.
Any other ideas?
So we have epistasis.
We have epigenetics.
We've got two E's so far.
Anything else?
How about if there are
a lot of different loci
that are influencing
a particular trait,
but the effect sizes
are very small.
That we've captured,
sort of the cream.
We've skimmed off the cream.
So we get 70% of the
variance explained,
but the rest of
the QTLs are small,
right, and we can't see them.
We can't see them because we
don't have enough individuals.
We're underpowered, right.
We just-- more individuals
more sequencing, right.
And that would be the only
way to break through this
and be able to see these
very small effects.
Because if the effects
are small, in some sense,
we're hosed.
Right?
You just can't see
them through the noise.
All those effects are
going to show up down here
and we're going to reject them.
Anything else, people
can think about?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you content
maybe the sum of some areas
that are-- sorry, the
addition sum of those guys
that have low effects.
Or is that not detectable
by any [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well,
that's certainly
what we're trying to do
with residuals, right?
This multi-round
round thing is that we
take all the things
we can detect
that have an effect with
a conservative cut off
and we get rid of them.
And then we say, oh,
is there anything left?
You know, that's hiding, sort
of behind that forest, right.
If we cut through the
first line of trees,
can we get to another
collection of informative QTLs?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if this
could be an overestimate also.
Like, for example,
if, when you throw out
the variance for
environmental conditions,
the environmental conditions
aren't as exact as we thought
they were between two yeast
growing in the same set, setup.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Then maybe you
would inappropriately
assign a variance to the
environmental condition
whereas some that could
be, in fact-- something
that wouldn't be explained by.
PROFESSOR: And probably
the other way around.
The other way around
would be that you thought
you had the conditions
exactly duplicated, right.
But when you actually
did something else,
they weren't exactly duplicated
so you see bigger variance
in another experiment.
And it appears to be
heritable in some sense.
But, in fact, it would just
be that you misestimated
the environmental component.
So, there are a
variety of things
that we can think about, right.
Incorrect heritability
estimates.
We can think about
rare variance.
Now in this
particular study we're
looking at everything, right.
Nothing is hiding.
We've got 50x sequencing.
There are no variants
hiding behind the bushes.
They are all there
for us to look at.
Structural variants-- well
in this particular case,
we know structural
variants aren't present,
but as you know, many
kinds of mammalian cells
exhibit structural
variance and other kinds
of bizarre behaviors
with their chromosomes.
Many common variants
of low effect.
We just talked about that.
And epistasis was brought up.
And this does not
include epigenetics,
I'll have to add
that to the listen.
It's a good point.
OK.
And then we talked
about this idea
that epistasis is the case
where we have nonlinear effects.
So a very simple
example of this is
when you have little a and
big B, and big A and big B
together, they
both had an effect.
But little a, little
b, have no effect.
And big A and big B have
no effect by themselves.
So you have a
pairwise interaction
between these terms.
Right.
So this is sort of the
exclusive OR of two terms
and that non-linear
effect can never
be captured when you're
looking at terms one at a time.
OK.
Because looking
one at a time looks
like it has no
effect whatsoever.
And these effects, of course,
could be more than pairwise,
if you have a complicated
network or pathway.
Now, what the authors
did to examine this,
is they looked at
pairwise effects.
So they considered
all pairs of markers
and asked whether or not,
taken two at a time now,
they could predict a
difference in trait need.
But what's the
problem with this?
How many markers did
I say there were?
13,000, something like that.
All pairs of markers is a
lot of pairs of markers.
Right.
And what happens to
your statistical power
when you get to
that many markers?
You have a serious problem.
It goes right through the floor.
So you really are very
under-powered to detect
these interactions.
The other thing
they did was to try
to get things a little
bit better as they said,
how about this.
If we know that a given QTL is
always important for a trait
because we discovered it
in our additive model.
Well consider its
pairwise interaction
with all the other
possible variants.
So instead of now
13,000 squared,
it's only going to be like
22 different QTLs for a given
trait times 13,000 to
reduce the space of search.
Obviously I got this explanation
not completely clear.
So let me try one more time.
OK.
The naive way to go at looking
at pairwise interactions
is consider all pairs
and ask whether or not
all pairs have an influence
on a particular trait value.
Right.
We've got that much?
OK.
Now let's suppose we don't
want to look at all pairs.
How could we pick one
element of the pair
to be interesting,
but smaller in number?
Right.
So what we'll do is,
for a given trait,
we already know which
QTLs are important for it
because we've built
our model already.
So let's just say, for
purpose of discussion,
there are 20 QTLs that are
important for this trait.
We'll take each one
of those 20 QTLs
and we'll examine whether or not
it has a pairwise interaction
with all of the other variance.
And that will reduce
our search base.
Is that better?
OK, good.
So, when they did
that, they did find
some pairwise interactions.
In 24 of their 46 traits
had pairwise interactions
and here is an example.
And you can see the dot plot,
or the upper right-hand part
of this slide,
how when you BYBY.
You have a lower
phenotypic value then
when you have just
any RM component
on the right-hand side.
So those were two
different snips
on chromosome 7
and chromosome 11
and showing how they
interact with one another
in a non-linear way.
If they were linear, then as you
added either a chromosome at 7
or a chromosome 11 contribution
it would go up a little bit.
Here, as soon as you add
either contribution from RM,
it goes all way up to have
a mean of zero or higher.
In this particular case, 71%
of the gap between broad-sense
and narrow-sense was explained
by this one pair interaction.
So it is the case that
pairwise interactions
can explain some of the
missing heritability.
Can anybody think
of anything else
they can explain
missing heritability?
OK.
What's inherited?
Let's make a list
of everything that's
inherited from the
parental line to the F1s.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
because there's
a lot more things inherited.
The protein levels
are inherited.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
are inherited as well.
PROFESSOR: Good.
I like this line of thinking.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There
are a lot of things
that are inherited, right?
So what's inherited?
Some proteins are
probably inherited, right?
What is replicable
through generation
to generation as a genetic
material that's inherited?
Let's just talk about
that for a moment.
Proteins are interesting,
don't get me wrong.
I mean, prions and other
things are very interesting.
But what else is inherited?
OK, yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So there are
other genetic molecules.
Let's just take a really
simple one-- mitochondria.
OK.
Mitochondria are inherited.
And it turns out that
these two strains
have can have
different mitochondria.
What else can be inherited?
Well, we were doing these
experiments with our colleagues
over at the Whitehead
and for a long time
we couldn't figure
out what was going on.
Because we would do the
experiments on day one
and they come out a
particular way and on day two
they come out a different way.
Right.
And we're doing some very
controlled conditions.
Until we figured
out that everybody
uses S288C which is the
genetic nomenclature
for the lab trained
yeast, right.
It's lab train because
it's very well behaved.
It's a very nice yeast.
It grows very well.
It's been selected
for that, right.
And people always do genetic
studies by taking S288C,
which is the lab yeast, which
has being completely sequenced
and so you want to use it
because you can download
the genome with a wild strain.
And wild strains come
from the wild, right.
And they come
either off of people
who have yeast infections.
I mean, human beings, or
they come off of grape vines
or God knows where, right.
But they are not well behaved.
And why are they
not well behaved?
What makes these yeast
particularly rude?
Well, the thing that makes
them particularly rude
is that they have things
like viruses in them.
Oh, no.
OK.
Because what
happens is that when
you take a yeast that
has a virus in it,
and you cross it with
a lab yeast, right.
All of the kids got the virus.
Yuck.
OK.
And it turns out that the
so-called killer virus in yeast
interacts with various
chromosomal changes.
And so now you
have interactions--
genetic interactions
between a viral element
and the chromosome.
And so the phenotype you get
out of particular deletions
in the yeast genome has
to do with whether or not
it's infected with
a particular virus.
It also has to do with which
mitochondrial content it has.
And people didn't
appreciate this
until recently because most of
the past yeast studies for QTLs
were busy crossing lab
strains with wild strains
and whether it was ethanol
tolerance or growth and heat,
a lot of the strains
came up with a gene
as a significant
QTL, which was MKT1.
And people couldn't understand
why MKT1 was so popular, right.
MKT1, maintenance
of killer toxin one.
Yeah.
That's the viral thing that
enables-- the chromosomal thing
that enables a viral competence.
So, it turns out
that if you look
at this-- in this
particular case,
we're looking at
yeast that don't
have the virus in the bottom
little photograph there.
You can see they're
all sort of, you know,
they're growing similarly.
And the yeast with the
same genotype above-- those
are all in tetrads.
Two out of the four are
growing, the other two
are not, because the other two
have a particular deletion.
And if you look at the
model-- a deletion only model,
the deletion only, only looks
at the chromosomal compliment
doesn't predict the
variance very well.
And if you look at the
deletion and whether or not
you have the virus,
you do better.
But you do even
better, if you allow
for there to be a
nonlinear interaction
between the chromosomal
modification
and whether or not
you have a virus.
And then you recover almost
all of missing heritability.
So I'll leave you with
this thought, which
is that genetics is complicated
and QTLs are great, but don't
forget that there are all
sorts of genetic elements.
And on that note,
next time we'll
talk about human genetics.
Have a great weekend until then.
We'll see you.
Take care.